There needs to be one day, a universal day;...
...that is all people all around the world just focus on peace.
The International Day of Peace becomes a total global observation.
It's observed around the world in every country.
And everyone on the planet knows about it and observes it on some level.
The International Day of Peace is an opportunity...
...for all of humanity to observe a day of peace together.
And in 1981, the UN established...
...by an announced resolution of all member nations, the International Day of Peace.
And through that, the world comes together as unified.
There are thousands and thousands of events all over the world...
...on the International Day of Peace.
What I believe that the International Day of Peace can do is really inspire people...
...especially the young people to really grasp that peace...
...is a value that I believe is in everybody's heart.
And somebody asked me what could they do on the International Day of Peace...
...and I said you can do anything that makes the world a better place.